well thank you very much um thank you
George and I just would like to start by
acknowledging your great work George I
think you are an incredible
environmentalist and campaigner I've
admired you for many years and I think
your book regenerates this uh the first
half of which I fully agree with is a
brilliant critique of what is wrong uh
with industrial farming including
livestock so there is so much we share
and for me it's very
disappointing uh that there's such a
polarization of our views over the role
of livestock in sustainable farming
systems because I agree with you that
the Livestock systems that predominate
all over the world at the moment are
definitely part of the problem but
rather than trade statistics with you
which we could do and no doubt we will
do it when I've had my six minutes and
and there's a bit of a you know back and
forward um I want to talk about my own
practical experience and because I think
that uh one of the reasons why I think
you doubt the capacity uh of farming to
transport in a way which will uh have
livestock really at the center of the
sustainable Food Systems which replace
the ones that we've got at the moment is
because you're not a practitioner I am a
practitioner um I'm within a month of
celebrating our 50th Anniversary here on
this 300 acre mainly livestock Farm you
know that we've grown vegetables along
the road and we've just talking about it
we used to be a carrot producer for
supermarkets we had to stop because the
system um got too centralized and I've
just been out today ridging up my
potatoes so I'm a a definitely a
vegetable grower but the main use of the
land on this bomm uh is for producing uh
livestock we have now a 90 C AA herd and
followers and uh we produce cheese as
Alice just said and um what is really
interesting about our farm after 50
years of not using any nitrogen
fertilizer and farming in harmony with
nature is the impacts the first of which
I want to focus on a little bit which is
carbon we just had a carbon audit and it
looks as though if you leave the data
that we are actually carbon negative in
other words the soil building of in the
permanent pasture and the rotations
because we do grow some oats and peas to
feed our cows um looks as if it not only
offsets the methane emission of the cows
but also the energy that we use on the
farm so we are net carbon negative now
obviously this is just one farm and I I
also want to speak about the nature
impacts uh you said that if we took more
land out of production to um if we if we
carried on um if we went to my system at
scale uh it would have devastating
impacts because we'd have to have more
land in production well the if you farm
in harmony with nature you have
fantastic biodiversity outcomes our farm
is alive with birds small mammals
insects amphibians all because we're not
farming in a hostile way and the like
the wildlife can coexist with the system
we also employ around seven full-time
equivalent lab units on the farm and so
if you take it together um we are
producing a lot of food we're producing
enough cheese to feed three 3,000 people
uh the milk we sell could feed another 2
and a half thousand and the meat which
comes either from the dairy cows at the
end of the lives or the male carbs can
feed another 500 now you might say this
is just one farm and what did you say
you said we're living in a state of
delusion well I I plead guilty I am in
in the state of delusion after 50 years
I'm convinced that my farming system
could go to scale and if you don't
believe me we did a report which we
published uh just recently called
feeding Britain from the ground up where
we modeled a nationwide transition of
farming to sustainable farming systems
operating within planetary boundaries
the sort of farming I'm doing here and
we looked at the impact on total food
output and the fascinating conclusions
are that could maintain and maybe even
slightly increase our national level of
food Security in our staple foods if we
switched to farming systems like the one
we are using here and if we scale that
globally yes we could feed the world but
only if we ate differently here's some
areas where we agree we give up all
industrial livestock farming uh no more
cheap chicken no more horrible pork from
industrial pork units or Mega daries you
mentioned there are Mega
near this Farm in kered in but if we if
we gave up eating meat it would be a
problem because the Farms that need the
farming systems that need to replace the
ones we've got at the moment would rely
on a rotation 50% of which at any one
time would be infertility building and
that would normally be Clover and grass
and to maximize the food output from uh
that system and actually I would say to
revitalize the soil we need livestock
grazing stock yes mainly grass spread
not exclusively grass spread in a Dairy
system but certainly with beef and lamb
production more or less a 100% grass-fed
and if we did that we'd actually have
quite a lot of meat to eat far more than
most people think what we have to give
up is the cheap chicken that everybody's
become used
to